you can do whatever you can accomplish
whatever you want in life but you can't
want whatever you want in life and what
that second part means is that if you if
you don't really truly want it there's
no faking it there's no half step can't
manufacture model and I think anybody
any of those people that are on Twitter
that you're referring to anywhere you
experience in life that say it's not
fair that's not true not anyone can make
it then I think that they're right that
because they will never make it because
they don't want it and they may think
they want it but if they actually wanted
it they would you know they would
probably have a mentality the mentality
that I understand which was the that
kids scrubbing pots which was just like
look I may never not I may never achieve
the level of success and I'm fantasizing
about in the bottom of this chowder pot
but I sure as [ __ ] will die before I
give up trying and I think it's that's
that's the want that I'm referring to
when I say not everybody can get to that
place and I believed I don't think that
that's an egalitarian I don't think
everybody has the same access point I
don't think that that's a fair because I
just don't think everyone can access
that mental space I think we have we
live in a world there's a lot of safety
nets I think that if we're all on a
highway there are exits everywhere that
are so much easier than persevering and
I think that unless you truly have that
kind of sociopathic resolve to achieve a
level of success a self-determined level
of success whatever whatever you set out
to accomplish unless you have that crazy
gene no you're gonna you're gonna choose
a path that's maybe a little bit less
has a little bit less resistance in
front of it and I would never fault
someone for that does that make sense it
totally makes sense
and I I i think the only part that
doesn't make sense to me is the
insistent insistence by a group of
people that complaining about the world
being unfair instead of
quickly acquiring skills and taking over
and building things which is open to
everybody is a lot less work in my mind
than sitting there on Twitter
complaining forever the average American
is watching five hours of TV a day and
you can learn to video edit and teach
yourself in I don't know a hundred hours
200 hours what would it take to be
generally good at using one of these
SLRs to shoot took you how long a
hundred hours 200 hours 10,000 okay ten
dollars you want to go with the Malcolm
Gladwell by the way you could if you got
rid of TV you would gain back 1,800
hours a year so you could be relatively
good at it in a couple of years yeah and
a master in v iii-vi I just I agree I
think I do think that the world is
unfair of course I think that for
whatever reason like a funny-looking big
nose Jewish kid from high school dropout
from Connecticut like I've just been
hard work and all that all that [ __ ] but
I also like have been tremendously lucky
tremendously
I mean I'm healthy I'm not inhibited by
any any health like the obstructions
that I faced in my career and in my life
have all been overcome abble so I think
that I think that there's a there's a
lot you can do to help skew luck but I
think that luck is a huge component of
success and I think that it's something
that's easy to cross over especially for
successful people but I'm I'm super
conscious of just how lucky I've been at
every single turn but you've been lucky
like 15 times so at a certain point like
some number of those are the massive
amount of effort you're putting in and
the resiliency yeah
of coure of course yeah and I would
never discount anyone's effort on their
way to success but I think that to not
acknowledge that there are there are
aspects aspects of a climb to success
that that are outside of your control
and everyone people do have different
levels of struggle so as hard as it was
for you with your dad being an equipment
salesperson you at least had two parents
present and they could have sort of any
sort of or you could have you could have
had no parents look I
I always say that like I started at zero
because you know as I'm welfare when my
kid was born we had nothing but I don't
I take that but I don't think that
that's a fair statement yeah you started
it like two and there were people who
had it rougher no I mean I think I
started at ten thousand I think I
started at a hundred thousand because I
think that what I had to overcome as
like a kid in southeastern Connecticut
who was you know on welfare and had a
baby that sounds like [ __ ] it couldn't
get worse than that but then you put
yourself out there you start to
understand this world a little bit I
think one of the most rewarding things
were done in my life and it was was
working with a nonprofit called treat
the pain and treat the pain distributes
morphine to people who are dying of AIDS
in rural Africa so I went around and
distributed these bottles of their local
bottles of milk but essentially was
abuse proof morphine cuz if you drink
enough to get high you immediately vomit
so you could only take enough to really
medicate your your your ailments and I
like met a bunch of really interesting
wonderful people on that journey through
Uganda but I remember meeting one girl
it took us six hours and Jeep to get to
her house to deliver this morphine and
she had AIDS because she was raped when
she was a very young child and she was
making a living making ends meet because
she would sell cookies to the local
people in her village I bought some
cookies they were great and I think that
if in her life if God willing she gets
to live to 70 80 years old if she were
to ever get to my zero she would
consider herself the luckiest girl in
the world and having the having you know
the benefit of getting to experience
that I realized like you want to talk
about luck yeah like being born in
America my luck of being born in America
my luck of you know having parents that
put food on the table my luck of a
public education system like
or being born in this era sure yeah my
luck of not being born and you know 1902
and getting shipped off to warp 15 years
later my luck of not having to you know
deal with physical ailments or being
born with a disease or any of those
things that's all luck that I didn't
work for that luck that had nuts the
lottery
that's the lottery and that's why I say
like no I didn't start [ __ ] crazy I
didn't start at zero I was born with a
golden ticket you know I was born to
healthy legs and to healthy arms and I'm
they can stand tall and I can speak and
I was born in America are you [ __ ]
crazy you know lucky I am yeah all this
other stuff is just icing absolutely